before the Senate cleared the way for
Brett Kavanaugh on Friday president
Trump blasted the protests that have
taken place during the confirmation
process in a tweet Friday morning the
president referred to the demonstrators
as quote paid professionals who were
trying to make senators quote look bad
he also called them troublemakers mr.
Trump has not spoken publicly publicly
rather since gaining the assurance that
he will place another justice on the
Supreme Court Paula Reid is at the White
House with more
good morning Paula good morning Michele
after a week of protests and uncertainty
here in Washington an official tells us
that the mood inside the White House is
one of happiness and relief now that
they know they have secured enough votes
to confirm judge Cowen ought to the
Supreme Court but even with the support
of senators Collins and Manchin we're
told the White House is not resting on
its laurels and they're gonna hold off
before celebrating until after the vote
later today but before Collins made her
announcement president tweeted the
president tweeted that he was very proud
of the US Senate for voting YES to
advance the nomination of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh but surprisingly he hasn't
said anything since the Cullens
announcement the one official reaction
from the White House came from Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who tweeted Thank You
senator Collins for standing by your
convictions and doing the right thing to
confirm judge Cavanaugh a vice president
Mike Pence also tweeted his support for
Cavanaugh yesterday calling him one of
the most qualified judges ever to be
nominated to the highest court in the
land as president of the Senate vice
president Pence often oversees important
Senate votes he oversaw the confirmation
vote for Justice Gorsuch and he is
expected to participate in the vote
later today the president and his allies
they've been using all the controversy
surrounding Cavanaugh on the campaign
trail this week to encourage his
supporters to vote in the midterms at a
rally in Minnesota Thursday the
president accused Democrats of trying to
destroy judge Brett Kavanaugh and while
the Cavanaugh confirmation process
certainly hasn't gone as the White House
hoped the upside was that they were
seeing this as sort of something that
was motivating Republican voters ahead
of these
critical midterms in what's unclear is
whether or not the president and his
allies will be able to sustain that
momentum once Cavanaugh is confirmed
Dana Paula Reid thank you very much